so today we're going to talk about the
best vitamin for
sciatica now what is sciatica sciatica
is pain down the sciatic nerve
now the sciatic nerve comes from your
lumbar spine all the way in the back
part of your leg
all the way down into the bottom of your
foot it's the longest nerve in the body
it's the
widest biggest nerve in the body and it
can create a lot of pain and misery
especially if you are in a situation
where you have to drive long periods of
time or you're sitting a lot
behind your desk so the sonic nerve
needs certain nutrients to function
correctly
but the deficiency that will create the
most damage on that nerve
is a vitamin b2 deficiency riboflavin
now you can also get sciatica from other
deficiencies as well
especially b12 and b1
so i would recommend taking the whole b
complex just to make sure
and i would also probably take what's
called ben photamine which is a
fat soluble b1 that's been
very helpful in peripheral neuropathy
pain in the bottom of the foot
so i also wanted to talk about
additional symptoms that can occur
if you're low in vitamin b2 so we talked
about peripheral neuropathy
that's nerve damage in the peripheral
which means it refers
down into either the arm or the leg
the limbs are weak skin lesions or skin
problems
swollen mouth or tongue or
red tongue breakdown of the nervous
system
okay i'm talking about the myelin sheath
the outer part of that nerve
which is related to this right here
cracked heel so the back part of your
heels if it's dry and cracking
that's a b2 deficiency oily skin
especially around your nose through here
and even hearing loss now a b2
deficiency could be created
because you're just not consuming the
foods that are high in b2
or more commonly it's a problem with
your gut
whether you have gut damage celiac
crohn's
diverticulitis or some type of
malabsorption
in your small intestine or even your
large intestine
let's say you took a bunch of
antibiotics one time and that destroyed
your ability to absorb nutrients that
could be why you're deficient in b2
in which case you just need to take a
lot more of b2 to get the absorption
the foods that are high in b2 are liver
beef clams and other shellfish
mushrooms nuts cheese
eggs fish and even green vegetables
now i have done other videos on sciatica
that you can check out i put the link
down below because it's not always a
vitamin deficiency
but it can be so check them out
and comment down below
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto absolutely not karen
and it's an immune system builder
absolutely
you have to check this out i think you
should hurry up watch the recipe
and make it yourself it's just so easy
to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it
you